you know the Summer Olympics begin just
one week from today down in Rio and
since this is flashback Friday why don't
we go back four years ago that's when
our women's gymnastics team the fierce
fight took on gold and they really took
home the hearts of everyone to mckayla
maroney was a member of that historic
team she was also the girl who smirk
launched a million me yeah well now
she's under attack from internet trolls
over her sexy new look you cross your
arms and you just kind of it was that
I'm not impressed whatever look that
became so viral Micaela even did it in
the White House with President Obama but
now the 20 year old has been targeted by
haters who are tearing apart her glam
selfies she's speaking out to our lauren
zima about rumors of plastic surgery on
her famous face I gotta ask you people
said that you did something to your lips
let's set the record straight no I'll be
very honest I have not done anything to
my face basically I'm wearing lip liner
and I wanted to like post something new
like you guys like there's such thing as
lip liner people on social media are
definitely like they're me it you know
she appeared in a music video for Jared
Leto's band thirty Seconds to Mars and
dabbled in acting sadly after a series
of injuries Mikayla will not compete in
Rio I had four different surgeries I had
a concussion right before the Olympics I
competed with a fractured shin and a
broken foot and I just kept going
I just wasn't I wasn't okay like I
couldn't get out of bed I was so sick I
was passing out all the time like I was
in the hospital just not doing well and
every time I would go back into the gym
I would hurt something or I would just
get really really sick
she idolizes Drake and starting her own
singing career keeping her voice under
wraps until her single ghost comes out
September 8 music for me is something
that is the most healing and it just I
feel so happy still a very gifted
athlete she says it's hard leaving
competition it was really hard for me to
accept that like you know gymnastics
comes to an end by the way only two
members from that gold medal team in
2012 are back in this Olympics Gabby
Douglas and Alli racing and the name to
remember the breakout star this time
around
Simone by